[Música]
e aí agora que o ronaldo para vocês em
eu já estou aqui a base de um boi velho
sorriu pra deixar o nariz e olha aí
começou a chover que está chovendo em
teresina está chovendo no piauí
eu como tenho muito gosto de chuva não
sei se é um mecanismo de defesa do do
meu nariz a chuva começa aí eu pensei
meu deus do céu que é isso vamos nos
fechar meu nariz entope de uma maneira
você não tem noção mas do mais tudo bem
eu voltei a fazer show e dvd com o show
aqui no canal já com mais de 15 milhões
de acessos mas eu voltei a fazer show um
show novo então é passar aqui na tela
nos lugares novos que vou fazer show
este mês está aí para ficar chato vou
fazer a minha da cia mesmo que eu faço o
começo do vídeo só que agora sem música
para vocês verem o qual é ridículo da
hora que eu gravo graças nesse site
primeira descrição do vídeo ela assistiu
50 tom mais escuro cara só que o
primeiro vídeo decidi que eu assisti ao
filme que eu fiz foi de 50 tom de cinza
na época sucesso 500 mil acessos bom que
eu fiz mas eu estava sempre esperança e
esse filme que eu queria ver como é que
esse filme que a continuação do seu
entanto chama 50 tons mais escuros têm
que se virar com melhor estado se você é
menores em todo mundo ea traição de
pornô
ver aquela visão esse site é proibido
para menores de 18 anos e tem 18 anos
entrar ou sair provavelmente vai ter
amigos e tenho sete anos a gente sabe o
que faz com que seu marido é de canto
mas depois não venham reclamar que esse
vídeo que a gente fala pra montar então
já vou deixando lá e aí e vão sofrer foi
a epal ter quem é o filme começa a
mulher recebe flores depois avaliar a
exposição de arte que é que aparece lá
pro stingray ó que anteriormente tinha
um contrato com ela pela sina haiti leva
sem contratar posso meter a mão atacar
possa enfim amontoando tocou contradizem
todas as coisas que ele podia fazer com
eles ela assinasse ele ia poder fazer
tudo e sair com ela
trata de brinquedos a ela não aceitou o
cargo ele nesse filme ele volta para
renegociar e negocia sem regras e sem
punições é dar um presente para lá é o
macbook air é um um iphone mas sempre me
sem compromisso iphones e em sete placas
selecionar 18 sem compromisso mas é a
média era mas só sem comprometimentos
apa e ela não quer aceitar essas coisas
eu por muito menos para me dar um cacho
de banana em caso de bolão tudo que para
tanto me amo cara e homem ciumento o
cristian greik é ciumento ele vê lá
conversando com o chefe de posto aqui
ele sai a gata falar à parte está
estressado demais cara eu tô sabendo eu
gostava de espera assim eu sei o que
pode ter se estressar eu falei hiv
[Música]
eles vão fazer compras não demorou muito
aos cara for pra casa de 1 10 minutos
agora com leite e porque ele tava de
joelho aqui né a mulher a mãe pega foi
dele a dizer que é o som do corpo dela
estava em pé a fender de perna fechada e
avance a ele encosta ela já começa bem é
o que todo mundo sabe que no ângulo e se
não tem convocado em ou seja para isso
acontecer o dardo liga tem que ser muito
grande ou então porquê dessa moeda tem
uma língua tão nariz em belém vené o
setor vai dormir acordaram ainda que
acordou com a normal nem traço café e
tal conversar um pouquinho e se beijaram
se eu queria te amo sei o que lá e deu
um cheque de 24 mil dólares para ela só
coisa normal que acontece no dia a dia
nos faz um tempo do filme ela começa a
descobrir que esse cara não é só o
tarado não ele é o trucida do bric ontem
um caderno com as fotos à informação de
todos a mulher que ele
eu falei que era ciumento ele é muito
ciumento domingo cristian greik ó é
muito melhor chama gente falar que a
mulher é indicado para não sair tem
gente pra deixar tem jeito é buscar a
minha trabalho trabalhador
de trabalho comprou o trabalho da menina
comprou o trabalho não gostar disse que
ela queria ter a vida dela queria
trabalhar eu queria fazer as coisas dela
e brigando com ele brinca briga público
no seu texto não sei quem você quer
conquistar o ouro
ele pega um negócio em franco deve rolar
ele pegou duas pedindo a pele falou o da
hora esse homem chega com o negócio
anunciado que envolvem a guitarra é é
algo a eles vão com um baile de máscaras
né ele pegue suas máscaras botas massa
que o baile de máscara que quando falha
de márcio careca e usava máscara a hoje
é baixo sem marcar ele usa aí não tem
mais mas foi de máscara entende tem
temas casa dele a pessoa já tanto contei
mas que seja real ou seja lá sentimental
ou máscara também quem sou eu para
julgar quando o fogo com um baile de
máscara e vai começar ele está lá e
botar a marca que ele tinha por que o
baile de máscara eles vão me afobar de
massa feliz uma coisa boa pois que não é
meu amigo se cada metro uns tapa na bola
dessa mulher que não está porque levava
nas costas quando era criança
depois rola rola e transei na etapa e na
fapa cara tirar mas também está
mostrando cunha a galera começa a
perseguir essa menina porque ela tá com
o solteiro mais cobiçado de nova iorque
nem ele mesmo cria se um grande quebra
quebra o carro dela joga tinta no carro
dela isso na garagem do sanduíches que
ele não se sente seguro marca amiga que
vai ficar com medo morro de medo 2 com
medo de tanto medo e não vou nem dormir
em casa verde onde no iate e medo meu
amigo meio daquela consultar ligado
àquela pensão aquela coisa de suspense
mesmo com medo com medo é saber que eles
a strans seguir até pai já no mpu a
taboa boe oito anos e vai continuar
ainda ter mulher pode estar na guerra a
terremoto e que o eleitor está acabando
e johansson pelo presidente
estadunidense público
no meio da guerra de tróia puxar achou
bala que seguir uma bala jogou a amante
quem a trabalha com a nova york que
acaba favorecendo vai com seu chefe
você vai comigo que para ele assim na
liga amanhã a casa bonita é seu ou
prevaleceu tudo ele pega meu amigo meu
deus do céu go ciência não é meio está
com você aquela casa é ter o que aquela
pedra pega pé compra pedras sem fio com
a pedra o chefe dela fica a jogar porque
o chefe do box é ela a denuncie o cara é
demitir o cara ou por trabalho já tinha
comprado combinou a copa 200 é como
carro chefe ela foi demitida ela
aumentou de cargas vão melhorar colegas
vão comemorar a adivinha fala pra mim é
com fogos não é com um bolo não olha a
tomar vão visitar a casa dele lá meu
amigo então naquele quarto alegando que
ele com arquitetos de bateias legal de
sentar para toraman acho ferro usam ele
pega o ferro só que ele pega o ferro que
segura assim ela é sim porque isso aí é
para ficar no clube é de ernando e até 2
segue tem como cabo toco nando a doida
esquerdo em fiasco num é de botão aqui
na pena dela é bota ou daquilo já para
segurar o pé na guerra aberta mas achei
que quer saber porque tem um carro ela
pede casa que este negócio ia fazer é
limitar a abertura à espera que alguém
botou o pé lá no tocantins outro lado da
mãe
resumindo o filme ela caminha ele ela
para ele como ela feira ele espera
cativar passar um pouquinho agora não
como ela realmente o cristian greik ó eu
fiquei tão impressionada com o filme
tetro é só assistir um filme de luta e
raça do filme avatar
eu ia se filtro é 2 chega em casa tão
impressionado os amores que é a ver
nessa prédio
até temos até pelo que o inferno por
filho teu cu falar da [__] roubado mas
com o que a colocou aqui ó para a
produção do queijo vai mal paga
simétricas olho na gente se você tiver
gostar deste vídeo já sabe fazer
apitarem gostei aqui no youtube não se
esquece você está carregando os vídeos
não se esquece de clicar em gosto feita
pois volta lá no facebook agora e clique
em curtir e marca seus amigos comentaram
olha ele assistiu 50 tom mais escuro e
lacuna é capricho em lei
ó
[Música]